joining me on the program today is Inga
Frick 'land a former prosecutor and an
executive board member of Law
Enforcement Against Prohibition which is
a non-profit group of criminal justice
professionals working to end the war on
drugs it's so great to speak to you and
we we actually have something newsworthy
to discuss here which is that Canada has
taken some major steps to end the war on
heroin users and we've been hearing so
much about legislation and lobbying
related to marijuana particularly in the
US but this is really very major news
let's start there what exactly has
Canada done well Canada has changed its
Controlled Substances Act so that it's
possible for a physician in a controlled
setting to supply pharmaceutical grade
injectable heroin to an addict for whom
no other treatment has worked it has to
be done in a controlled setting and it
seems to be you know fairly tightly
circumscribed to make sure that it's all
everything is signed off and it is in a
medical setting and when we talk about
one of the main sort of impediments in
the United States anyway to when it
comes to marijuana loosening laws we
often encounter this sort of vicious
circle which is a politician say I'm
open to loosening the laws as soon as we
have more research but of course the
research is difficult to do because the
laws are so tight as Canada experienced
a sort of similar dynamic with heroin
there does I I don't know if it's the
research is prohibited in the same way
that it is here but it's difficult in
reading some of the legislative history
on this new Act it refers to a couple of
studies that had been done and they also
looked at European experience which of
course has done research for a long time
so it's it's primarily at the United
States that takes this very emotional
and
active attitude toward even gaining
knowledge about drugs and some more put
our head in the sand and pretend the
problem doesn't exist when did you start
to I don't know if realize is the right
word but to really become increasingly
concerned with the futility of the war
on drugs in the US I know that you
worked as a prosecutor in Cook County
and and you I've read that you've
started to see the sort of racially
disproportionate way in which the war on
drugs was impacting people but give us a
sense of sort of your involvement
directly in the war on drugs and how
your views started to change this was
back in the mid 1980s when I was a young
prosecutor in Chicago I spent a lot of
time being assigned to the bond courts
where the people would come in usually
in the middle of the night when they
were first arrested and I would look at
the rap sheets sometimes could be page
after page of minor arrests and
convictions mostly for drugs and then
the new arrests would also be something
drug-related I also noticed that a lot
of the more serious cases including
murders it turned out to be a fight over
some drug territory so it looked like
drugs were driving a lot of our caseload
and at first I didn't give a whole lot
of thought to it because I thought hey
drugs are illegal drugs are bad these
people were doing drugs so will convict
them but it maybe it was kind of like
water dripping it gradually sank in
first of all I noticed that almost
almost without exception the defendants
were black few Hispanics virtually no
whites and even though we know that
usage of drugs is pretty similar across
racial groups the drug laws were clearly
falling much more heavily for some
reason on minority communities second
thing that got me thinking is that given
the restrictions that many employers
have somebody with a rap sheet
like this is never going to get a job in
the legitimate economy so essentially
our convictions weren't solving whatever
we thought the problem was but it was
digging people deeper into the drug
economy we made it so that they would
never be able to get out and sure enough
I would see these repeat customers same
people showing up week after week we'd
send them out they went back to dealing
drugs since that was probably their only
option and if they survived getting shot
in the middle of some turf warfare
they'd be back again so it looked as
though we were locked almost in this
dance that the prosecution we did the
same thing day after day they did the
same thing day after day and nothing
changed now except for did you see were
there any particular cases that stood
out to you where you said you know the
big picture of this just makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever aside
from the sort of generalities that you
talked about were there specific cases
that really impacted you I can't think
of there was such a similarity to the
cases that especially the ones involving
marijuana nothing really stood out if
anything it was the sameness of it that
got to me you know these the defendants
were becoming this undifferentiated mass
that were treated now with no interest
or respect from the prosecution that we
just kept cycling through kind of mass
production yeah that that steady drip
drip drip and then after I spent time in
the prosecutor's office then I moved on
to doing some other things and didn't
give them matter a whole lot more
thought well one of the other things it
that's fascinating to me is the time you
spent in Helmand province in Afghanistan
which when we think about the war on
drugs in the u.s. maybe for some of us
we see a connection to what's going on
in Afghan
Stan but but many people maybe don't see
that I'd love to hear a little bit about
that
oh my thoughts really started to
crystallize beginning in 2004 when I
first went to Afghanistan with the US
Agency for International Development and
between 2004 and 2014 I've been on the
ground in Afghanistan for just about
five years so I have seen and at the
course of the war and how much worse and
worse it's gone and what's happening
with drugs early on one of the things I
remember is meetings at the u.s. embassy
of what agriculture programs could be
developed to try to get African farmers
to grow something other than poppy right
and a meeting at the Embassy I said have
we considered just legalizing drugs okay
the answer that I got was that is not US
government policy and you had better not
bring it up again
but it really gets to the heart of this
issue right which is that we are
creating so much of what we claim to
want to fix around the world by virtue
of our drug policy in the United States
yes and the whole poppy production in
Afghanistan is driven by demand actually
more in Western Europe and Russia than
in the US we get ours from South and
Central America but the US government
there was treating it as a supply
problem if we can only convince African
farmers to grow wheat which pays them
about 20th as much but one of the things
that struck me about that conversation
and something which very much bothers me
about the whole war on drugs is the
intellectual dishonesty of it if we're
going to say it's our policy to have
opium poppy be illegal let's also take
into consideration what are the
inevitable consequences of that
there is going to be violence and
corruption within Afghanistan now we
can't pretend that this war on drugs is
costless and the intellectual dishonesty
of being unwilling to apply some logical
analysis to the problem just like the
intellectual dishonesty of having
marijuana be Schedule one now the legal
definition is highly addictive and no
known medical use well that's simply
counterfactual you know I'm not one of
the the types that relies and points to
the free market in all cases in fact
quite the opposite but I'm also just
stunned when we ignore the fact like in
the example you gave of hey let's just
convince these Afghani farmers to grow
wheat instead of instead of opium
instead of poppy what that ignores the
market realities and and sometimes we
actually do have to pay attention to
them don't we oh absolutely and I
remember once when I was living out at a
small military base in eastern
Afghanistan which now seems to be Isis
territory some young staffer from the
embassy flew out from Kabul to give us
all the word on the latest plans for the
war on drugs and I remember him saying
those greedy African farmers they would
survive if they just grew wheat but they
want the money from the heroin and when
we are talking about Afghan farmers
living in mud-brick villages
statistically a quarter of their
children are going to die before the age
of five and we're talking about them
being greedy I just found that so
offensive yeah
no doesn't make sense on many many
levels I wish we had more time we have
been speaking with Inga Frick hland
former prosecutor and executive board
member for Law Enforcement Against
Prohibition thanks so much for talking
to us both about what's happening in
Canada with heroin but also your
experience absolutely fascinating
it has been well thanks for having me on